hello welcome to game life I'm Chris
caller
and I'm Peter Ruben and we are here at
the e3 expo where we are about to go
check out the talk of the show the
oculus rift VR headset
crazy
that's pretty great I gotta say that's
my first time did I look like an idiot
that's not that that would be a concern
it was good like there were a couple
moments where I would overall not not
experience we're always looking at what
is the improvement that we need to get
to to get something super mark there are
still a few more things to go before
it's consumer ready we're still trying
to figure out what is the our input also
you know right now we're keyboard and
mouse or gamepad what is VR input and
it's probably something a little more
limb hand oriented everybody has that
wish within a few seconds they wish they
were closer to the holodeck we do too
and we want to get it there for the
consumer version oh my god that you're
madman
what do you think of that extraordinary
and somehow I'm actually really really
here really here and like I know that
I'm talking to people who are in this
room but I've kind of mentally lost the
topography of this room so what do you
think I'm just gonna keep stone guy and
this would make plane flights pass by so
quickly like the room that I physically
am sitting in right now I kind of forget
what it looks like
welcome back
no words honest naw man that was I I've
been hearing about this for a long time
fine getting the experience is a whole
and I've used the oculus rift before but
like when they saw that HD 1080p had set
down over my eyeballs it was like oh man
it's like actually being there oculus
kind of wants consumers to wait for the
full-on HD version you're gonna make
some more tweaks to it when they release
in her to the public and I understand
the curiosity and why so many people
snapped up those developers oh sure yeah
but at Lund but trust us when we say
that that polished version of seeing
that 1080p you're gonna want to wait for
this it's a it's a it's a quantum leap
over the development kit for sure now we
still don't know when I feel it's going
to be releasing the oculus VR headset
but you know they're gonna do it when
it's done thank you very much for
watching game life we have been checking
out the oculus VR thanks being err